[Musique]
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour jean
jacques bourdin merci d'être avec nous
vous présidez le groupe ait l'air au
sénat bruno retailleau vous êtes
vous-même sénateur bruno retailleau
nous allons parler de la paix à blanc
par les deux des sujets d'actualité mais
j'aurais commencé par la déclaration des
manuels mâcon sur l'immigration on ne
peut pas accueillir tout le monde serait
d'accord avec lui
oui bah oui oui oui bon bah vous êtes
content république l'homme et je crois
que se méfie des propos à gmail mc ren
parce que au bout d'un peu plus de deux
ans de pouvoir
on commence à mieux le connaître et je
pense que là où il est le plus fort sans
communication
il ya un an nous avons un nous nous
l'avons rejetée au sénat mais a été
promu lier la loi des mails macron sur
l'asile l'immigration ya juste un an et
nous l'avions prévenu que cette loi
donnerait rien et d'ailleurs il a
reconnu lui même à la conférence des
ambassadeurs que la france était
désormais le premier pays d'europe pour
le rebond pour les déboutés du droit
d'asile qui convergent en france donc sa
loi ne marche pas qu'est ce que moi je
demande je vais vous dire où la
politique c'est des résultats quand même
oui on demande un présent de république
n'ont pas de faire des lois pour rien
non pas comment dirais-je de commenter
ses propres échecs mais de décider donc
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est comme il le
dit lui même parfois de la peep ou est
ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il va et qu'il ait décidé des mesures
faire apparemment des mesures sont en
préparation réduction des conditions du
regroupement familial
qu'est ce qui a encore durcissement de
l'attribution des aides sociales
augmentation vous prendre exemple
regroupement famille il ya un an mais sa
loi où il lui avait dit écoutez on va
aligner les conditions de regroupement
familial sur le rhum
il avait dit non ils avaient dit non et
pire ils avaient même élargi les
conditions pour les mineurs réfugiés aux
frères et soeurs ce qui n'existait pas
avant
il avait élargi le regroupement familial
donc qui faut-il croire et belle macro
quand y présente une loi qui voter par
sa propre majorité ou emmanuel mâcon qui
constate aujourd'hui un échec
j'ai emmené avec moi un petit document
qui est très intéressant que chaque élu
parlementaire devrait lire il est de
didier leschi didier leschi celle où je
connais
de l'office français de l'immigration il
vient plutôt d' à gauche et bien c'est
accablant
c'est dit avec beaucoup de justesse je
prends juste une phrase la france est
désormais un des rares pays où la
réunification familiale peut se faire
pour les réfugiés comme pour les
bénéficiaires la protection des eaux
qu'il faut changer cela et pour les
étrangers malades
idem il faut changer ce bien sûr il faut
changer bord bien seuls les propositions
d'ailleurs fait des propositions je ne
sais pas moi des objectifs annuels fixés
par le parlement pour l'immigration
l'économie vient seulement je suis
apprécié par amitié par me disent que je
pense que oui le grand problème en
france marcel gauchet le disent beaucoup
mieux que moi c'est que l'immigration
est un sujet c'est sans doute un des
sujets qui a transformé le plus
profondément la société et qui était
pour autant tenu à l'écart de la
délibération du peuple ou de leurs élus
et je pense que c'est au parlement de
voter et non pas à la rue de au café du
commerce d'émettre un certain nombre
d'idées
moi je suis pour que chaque année le
parlement vote des plafonds des
migrations par métier où est le problème
c'est que depuis trente ans beaucoup de
majorité se sont succédé avec des
intentions je me souviens de nicolas
sarkozy finalement emmanuel macro
nicolas sarkozy se ressemblent beaucoup
non non et finalement peu d'effet
derrière un peu d'actes mais par ce nom
et pour un appel courage quoi courage
absolument la droite comme la gauche et
moi je le dis moi oui je joue et je vois
je veux pas porter tous les péchés du
monde nos jambes je fais partie d'aucun
gouvernement
je ne me sens lié par la personne
personne et je pense que souvent c'est
vrai notre passé a été un passif c'est
ce que nous reproche nos propres
électeurs aujourd'hui qu'ils détournent
de nous moi j'ai des propositions à
faire sur le vote du parlement j'ai des
propositions à faire en matière de
moncel frontex
bien sûr les frontières mais rémy les
frontières nationales mais comment
rétablir des frontières nationales mais
touchette bourdin c'est le cas schengen
prévoit et s'est établi à la suite
oui c'est vrai qu'avoir novembre et des
grands attentats je vais vous dire chers
et à bayonne
bien sûr et bien faut oui mais sauf que
c'est aujourd'hui une situation
particulière on a besoin de 3 frontière
une frontière très avancés avec des hot
spots sur les pays d'origine une
frontière avec schengen
gardes-frontières je vais même au delà
je pense que on aurait dû prolonger
l'opération sofia de l'union européenne
qui consistait à détruire les moyens des
passeurs je pense qu'à des actions
militaires a mené contre les nouveaux
esclavagiste on le peut il faudrait pour
cela passer à lui est nue en une
résolution et on doit modifier
totalement notre législation sur le
regroupement familial sur l'aide
médicale d'état
j'ai fait des propositions et au sénat
tous les ans nous votons la amy voulait
transformer l'aide médicale d'état en
aide médicale d'urgence lundi
contagieuse les maladies infectieuses
mais on ne peut pas ouvrir à toute la
misère du monde le droit aux soins bien
sûr qu'ils pas question c'est de laisser
mourir géré étrangers parce qu'il
coachait milliards d'euros non me jean
jacques bourdin ya pas une solution à
une seule il ya une dizaine de lucio
mais il faut du courage
avec le courage d'appliquer les lois
aussi qui existe parce qu'on a des lois
qui existent qui sont j'ai tourné
regardez par exemple sur les visas pour
les soins il suffit désormais de montrer
que même si le soin existe dans le pays
d'origine que on a des difficultés
d'accès pour y avoir droit en france
c'est pratiquement le seul pays européen
qui agit de cette façon là bien merci
bruno retailleau de réagir sur ce sujet
de parler de pragmatisme finalement du
président de la république même si vous
ne croyez pas aux discours au fond du
discours mais le résultat pragmatisme
aussi sur l'aide à l'emploi à domicile
des seniors
oui j'avais vu que le gouvernement à
reculer très bien le prêt très bien bien
sûr c'est une bonne idée
non ce qui n'était pas une bonne ou la
mauvaise idée parce qu'avant la bonne
idée de recul le couac c'est ce qui a
généré le couac
et là il ya quand même une logique voyez
cette logique elle a consisté à
désindexer les retraites d'abord elle a
des années qu'elle a consisté à frapper
avec la csg les retraités est désormais
s'était notamment ses aides au domicile
alors que le vieillissement est
important ce que je constate quand même
c'est que les vieux les aînés sont pas
des privilégiés
c'était une génération sociale qui
étaient supprimés bien sûr mais oui
voilà vous avez trois exemples et ce qui
est troublant schemel macron c'est que
y'a un détricotage du lien social par le
haut c'est à dire la mise en fragilité
de nous aider mais aussi par le bas
notamment les descendants la politique
familiale qu'elle hérite personne n'en
parle
versement par on va traiter du sujet des
retraites on a un système par
répartition les actifs payent pour les
retraités
si on a un effondrement de la natalité
de la politique familiale qui soutient
la natalité
il y aura un problème de main pour le
rétablissement de toutes manières j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure la réforme des
retraites meilleur un problème alors je
voudrais vous parler du climat
comment osez vous comment osez-vous
bruno retailleau vous avez entendu et
greta turnberry
vous êtes dirigeant comment osez vous
vous allez regrets regardez vous l'avez
regardé bien sûr j'ai regardé quels vous
ressenti je me suis posé une question
oui quelle est la machine qui se cache
derrière de qui pourrait être mais
pourquoi voulez vous qu est une machine
derrière vous croyez jean jacques
bourdin franchement vous des monnaies
alors des roues simples lâchement
bourrel d'anaïs sept ans oui vous n'êtes
pas naïf vous pensez qu'elle se retrouve
à l'onu tout seul sans aucun souci là je
pense qu'elle porte je vais vous dire je
vends ce que je pense qu'elle portait
elle un mois le porte une ceinture
je ne la mets beaucoup mais l'angoissé
ou génération y en a qui n'est pas la
nôtre mais c'est moi parler mais plaisir
elle met en accusation
oui des pays qui sont les moins coupable
la france 1% de rejets de gaz à effet
serre met-elle en accusation la ji la
chine pratiquement 30% 28% mettre des
landes en accusation les états unis
parce que l'avion est facile et elle
n'est bien sûr mais bien sûr mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que les
français ils comprennent de ce point de
vue là quelles solutions proposez vous
dites mais vous vous êtes dirigeant
mais moi je vous réponds j'ai vécu moi
en vendée eric à la catastrophe ya très
exactement 20 ans vous avez la marée
noire c'est moi qui ai fait inscrire
dans le code civil français
pour la première fois la notion
juridique de préjudice écologique pour
que les payeurs puisse payer vraiment
quand ils sont au leurre le préjudice
mais avant le préjudice il faut prévenir
bien sûr mais je la vide avancions mais
je suis là on fait des solutions alors
moi je suis solution noir vous posez
solution est ce que vous l'avez entendu
proposer une solution
moi je suis contre cet écologisme
catastrophique sans doute joue-t-il un
rôle sans doute utile un rôle à travers
l'émotion pour un éveil mais il faut des
solutions il faut quitter le yaka fokon
alors vous allez nous donner vos
solutions parce que si elle en fait trop
n'est ce pas parce que les dirigeants
n'en font pas assez bien sûr meyrin bien
sûr je moi je fais des rangs des
éditions je veux bien qu'on la cheville
vendredi 6 être gêné par ses propos par
son attitude son comportement mais à la
raison sur le fond les dirigeants n'en
font pas assez je leur fais des
propositions faites vous je fais par
exemple de proposition je pense que il
faut que l'europe puisse construire une
protection douanière pour des preuves
pour des produits qui sont des produits
qui ont une approche et n'empruntent
carbone ou qui sont des profs qui on
intègre des normes qui sont plus basses
que nos propres normes standards en
protection d'environnement et se font
c'est insuffisant mais non on le
mettrait dans un fond vert ça limiterait
à fond vert avec ce fonds vert je
propose puisque les taux d'intérêt sont
quasiment nulles oui je propose qu'on
fasse un énorme emprunt de plusieurs
centaines de milliards pour que on
investit dans la recherche moi je ne
crois pas ne faisons pas de l'écologie
une forme de nouvelles religions
essayons de travailler avec la science
avec la raison la deuxième chose
abandonnons les traités type mercos ou
rousse état
qui détruisent encore une fois un
certain nombre de l'environnement je
fais d'autres propres chaussures est ce
qu ont interdit l'importation du soja
brésilien
eh bien écoutez oui il faut interdire
l'importation du soja brésilien
pour l'instant son genre mais bien
contribuer à la déforestation amazon et
bien sûr oui bien sûr oui ou non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas étudié
ce sujet non mais je attendez je ne
réponds jamais par oui ou par aman pour
congés pas et puis à fond un dossier
simplement ce que j'ai étudiée si le
ceta ou le mercosur qui détruisent qui
consiste à détruire un important des
produits qui par exemple le mercosur
au brésil on utilise 74% des molécules
de pesticides notamment qui sont
interdites en france en europe on peut
pas amener ses produits en france
pour moi c'est une évidence qu'il faut
cesser de subventionner l'industrie des
énergies fossiles je pose la question
oui ou non je pense que oui je pense que
oui je pense qu'il faut progressivement
avoir un mix énergétique
moi je suis pour le nucléaire autour de
50% regardez le giec
même si j'ai vu les chiffres l'à-propos
le giec le coûteux jhr tout lé bien sûr
mais mieux j avec dans tous les
scénarios du giec
il recommande cette énergie qui est une
énergie décarbonée et il faut à bien sûr
avoir un mix énergétique à partir du
photovoltaïque de l'éolien et aussi bien
sûr de la biomasse en vendée nous on a
développé du gnv c'est-à-dire un gaz
liquéfié qui permet à des cars scolaires
le rouler proprement à partir de la
biomasse
ça c'est des solutions je crois que
total annoncent vouloir augmenter les
dividendes pour ses actionnaires
au passage mais bon
dites moi si nous parlions de la pma
sévère par lançant alors la pma j'ai pas
vu grand monde à l'assemblée nationale
et pour les premiers débats nous allons
voir ce que ça va donner cette pma alors
cette paix m'a ouvert à toutes les
femmes vous êtes contre je l'avais dit
j'y suis défavorable
vous y êtes des phases et évrier
rencontre où une res je veux très
content on était en train de parler de
l'environnement oui le l'homme a joué
aux apprentis sorciers avec la nature
voilà je pense qu' il ne faut pas qu'on
joue non plus l'apprenti sorcier avec la
nature humaine je pense que tant qu'on
ne m'aura pas montré définitivement que
pour se construire un enfant n'a pas
besoin de l'image du père tant qu'on ne
m'aura pas dit que le père compte pour
rien finalement qu'on peut l'effacer
eh bien je pense qu'il faut appliquer le
pratiquer le principe de précaution on
applique le principe de précaution on
s'en gargarise souvent pour la nature
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
l'appliqueraient pas justement sur la
nature humaine
je comprends les souffrances je
comprends le désir d'enfant non ne peut
pas y avoir un droit à l'enfant il ya
d'abord le droit de l'enfant où j'irai
manifester le 6 non je n'irai pas
manifester pourquoi parce que je pense
que contrairement au mariage pour tous
où j'avais manifesté
je pense que sur ce sujet là je pense
que sur ce sujet là on a une sorte de
convergence de gens qui sont de droite
et de gauche
sylviane agacinski et vient de la gauche
josé bové de la gauche de natacha polony
plutôt de gauche et caetera et caetera
et je pense qu'il faut pas politiser
parce que ce sera je pense pour les
manifestations j'encourage ceux qui
veulent manifester à y encourager mais
vous n'irez pas quoi absolument parce
que je pense que j'ai d'autre moyen de
m'exprimer je le fais aujourd'hui avril
cros je le ferai au sénat mais je pense
que si demain c'est la droite qui
manifestent ce sera tellement facile de
caricaturer
vous savez bien et je pense que c'est
des sujets qui sont tellement graves
caricature enfin bon je vais pas entrer
dans ce débat mais je voudrais me
souvenir parce que je me joindrai me
souvenir
bruno retailleau du pacs
je me souviens de la droite qui était à
fond contre le pacs je voudrais même pas
redire relie tous que la droite a dit à
l'époque
lorsqu'on a mis en place le pacs le
mariage pour tous on a parlé de quoi de
clonage de risque de clonage de risque
de décadence mais finalement on vit avec
et très bien mais finalement qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient été dénoncés retailleau
jean jacques bourdin
qu'est ce qui avait été dit 720 heures
c'est que le pacs passé business au
mariage le mariage menait à la pma vous
m'auriez reçues au moment du mariage
mais il n'est pas question de faire la
paix même pu noter que vous rêvez la
pema n'est pas dans le texte on est à la
pma pour tous y compris pour des femmes
seules et sans doute peut-être même sur
du post post m et là on va directement
sur la gpa vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on a légalisé
en france les effets les conséquences
juridiques d'une pma frauduleuse qu'on
fait à l'étranger
vous savez que recourir à une mère
porteuse catégorie autour du riz mais
non il n'y aura pas de gp a autorisé en
france mais s'aimer mais regardez les
fresques monsieur touraine hier qu'est
ce qu'il a dit le rapporteur monsieur
toi mia d'écouter la gpa éthiques
l'ag père et x il ya à gaza ce qui
traite cela en disant que c'est une
plaisanterie de mauvais goût te de
parler de la gta éthique il dit avançons
pas à pas donc on avance pas à pas la
meilleure preuve c'est la cour de
cassation c'est la cour d'appel de paris
qui ont légalisé les conséquences de jeu
de gpa à l'étranger donc aujourd'hui je
le dis aux français non mais je dis aux
français permet de paix mais je vous dis
que la pema parce que au nom de quoi
vous allez autorisé des couples de
femmes
avoir un enfant et que vous interdire y
ait au couple d'hommes d'avoir un enfant
puisque le ressort de tous ardent et
l'égalite ailleurs des sénateurs
lr sont favorables je n'ai bien sûr
parce que très que j'en ai vu très peu
le président de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat parce qu'on à
oui mais on a fait 145 où hélas parce
que ça questionne des consciences
individuelles
évidemment évidemment qu'on est pas mal
non et c'est tant mieux ça qu'on n'ait
pas une caserne mois à qui appartient
son corps à quercia son corps oui a dû
soi même à soi même mais justement c'est
le fond de la question bien j'ose
retailleau et bien c'est là où vous
voyez on a une grande différence je
pense que là où je m'oppose à la pma
parce que je pense qu'elle va conduire à
la gpa je pense que même une femme
consentante kiev qu'accepte porter un
enfant qui va donner son enfant au delà
du lien qui s'est créé pendant la
gestation
cette femme même si parce que d'habitude
il ya toujours de l'argent c'est une
marchandisation jean jacques bourdin
c'est les hommes riches de nos pays qui
paieront le ventre les ici des blocs
mais m ha oui la gp mais justement
appareils non annoncé c'est la
continuité et on n'a pas le droit de
donner ce qu'on ne possède pas même une
femme qui ne touchera pas un centime
d'euro elle n'a pas droit de donner ce
qui est un sujet et non pas un objet un
enfant bien mais la gpa n'est pas le
sujet de la discussion
je pense qu'il y aura la marchandisation
des jeux le processus de marchandisation
je pense que on a déjà une pénurie de
gamètes il va y avoir évidemment une
duplication partout par trois chacun
reconnaît qu est ce qui va se passer
vraisemblablement comme la belgique on
ira sans doute acheter des gamètes à
l'étranger ils le font au danemark donc
on va là encore écorché un des grands
principes éthiques france est l'un des
grands principes de notre modèle
français
c'est à dire la gratuité altesse que dès
le
le conseil national d'éthique oui mais
regardez l'académie de médecine ont
failli académie de médecine et je vous
fais et le principe c'est la vigilance
est aussi qui est proche
nous en sommes à tes et non pas proche
de mais jean-françois nive pour tous non
écoutés fo jean claude mailly est un
généticien peu mais vous voyez bien mais
non mais le temps que vous et d'autres
jacques bourdin vous prenez des avis
quand ils vous arrange
mais quand il ya des as jeunes défendent
avec séculière ici il ya soixante neuf
médecins qui appartient à l'académie
mais si c'est pas n'importe qui qui ont
même s'ils votent contre onze et vous
dites mais c'est dévié où ils sont
proches voulaient disqualifié voulait
disqualifié parce que leur avis ne vous
convient et non et bien moi je dis que
leur avis est important et je pense que
au delà des certitudes et qui avait
gravi le ravi de dire que c'est pas sans
conséquence de priver délibérément un
enfant d'un même n'affirme pas les jeux
de ballon et vous pourrez voir dans mon
entourage et pour connaître ou dans mon
entourage ou ce genre de questions je
sais que ça vous tient toute une vie
voyez ces question de l'origine ces
questions du manque d'une figure
paternelle ça vous tient mais une déjà
un enfant né de pma pourra à 18 ans il
le souhaite si la loi est votée
connaître son origine à clous alors là
aussi ce sera
c'est bien on enfreint ses biens
deuxième principe c'est l'anonymat
moi je suis pour parce que je pense que
alors eu à connaître ses origines c'est
bien mais croyez-vous simplement que
connaît son origine à 18 ans alors qu'on
est déjà construit ce soit suffisant
croyez moi je ne le pense pas et je le
dis par expérience bien bruno retailleau
j'ai une autre question vous poser parce
que c'est l'actualité aussi j'ai vu que
jean luc mélenchon avait traité des
policiers de barbares aurait vu ça avant
tendu j'ai attendu et alors je n'avais
jamais connu parce qu'il était sénateur
webb ajusté gmail gmail écouté par
soyeux c'était un grand républicain mais
là je trouve que le trotskiste prend le
pas sur républicain parce que traiter de
barbares la police de la république
c'est franchir un cap
une ligne rouge je crois nos policiers
et nos gendarmes nous protège ils nous
protègent contre les violences nous
sommes un état de droit
nous sommes une démocratie et ils sont
cet outil de la démocratie
et traiter de barbares les policiers ou
les gendarmes c'est atteindre un
principe à la fois prêt public 1 et
démocratique je le crois sincèrement je
le dis d'ailleurs avec une forme de
regret parce que je pense qu'au fond de
lui
je pense qu'il a une autre idée répandue
y est importé par sa fureur mais
peut-être je pense qu'encore une fois
les racines trotsky trotter plus forte
que les racines républicaine bruno
retailleau lr la présidence ou ne
prenait pas position
vous avez suivi peut-être et xavier
bertrand qui dit sous certaines
conditions je serai candidat à la
présidence de la république en 2022
mais vous c'est sans doute certaines
conditions pas pourquoi pas écoutez moi
je crois pas non sous certaines
conditions je porte
moi j'ai comment dire oui j'ai une ligne
oui j'y suis fidèle et j'ai des
convictions oui moi je constate qu' il y
aura un candidat qui portera mes
convictions et je l'aiderai si je
constate qu'aucun des candidats qui
pourraient venir de la droite et qui
pourraient se présenter
deux portes ces conditions alors j'aurai
imposer cette question qui est une
question grave évidemment oui mais vous
vous la poserait bien sûr me poserai
merci bruno retailleau d'être venu de
voir ce matin il est 8 heures 54